[موسيقى]
اللحوم النباتية أو اللحوم المقلدة كما
قد يسميها البعض ، تحظى بشعبية كبيرة
خاصة في وول ستريت ، حيث تتحول اللحوم المزيفة
إلى أرباح حقيقية في سوق
الأسهم لما وراء اللحوم ، وقد تجاوزت
أهم الاكتتابات الأولية لعام 2019 حتى الآن.
- على غرار ما يلي
سيكتسح العالم ، مهمتنا بسيطة للغاية
وهي استبدال
الحيوانات تمامًا كتكنولوجيا غذائية بحلول عام 2035 ،
إنها في الأساس تقنية
ما قبل التاريخ مثل ما قبل التاريخ مثل تناول
البروتين النباتي ليس
شيئًا جديدًا تمامًا ولا  برغر نباتي
لهذه المسألة ، فإن البرغر النباتي
هنا مغذي وخالٍ تمامًا من اللحوم ،
فلماذا تزداد شعبية الشركات مثل
الأطعمة غير
اللائقة والمستحيلة الآن ،
لاحظ أن عبوات هذه
المنتجات لا تتضمن كلمات مثل
نباتي أو نباتي  في أي مكان عليها وهذا عن
قصد ،
فنحن نهتم فقط بشكل قاطع
بأكل اللحوم ، ولا ينجز
أي شيء لبيع اللحوم للنباتيين
ولكن بيع قاعدة نباتية  إن تناول اللحوم إلى
آكلى لحوم ليس بالأمر السهل تمامًا
، ولهذا السبب وراء اقتناع محلات السوبر ماركت بعيدًا عن اللحوم ،
يجب وضع منتجاتها
مباشرة في ممر اللحوم ، كما أن
الأطعمة المستحيلة تتعاون مع
سلاسل الأطعمة الشعبية
لتقديم بديل نباتي لموادها الأساسية
عناصر القائمة ، الإستراتيجية واضحة لبيع
اللحوم النباتية حيث يتسوق آكلو اللحوم
فعليًا ، لذلك عندما
تتسوق لنفسك
منتجات لحوم العائلة بأكملها التي تمت الموافقة عليها من قبل
وزارة الزراعة الأمريكية وحتى
الآن تقول الشركات هذا هو  العمل في
النصف الأول من 2018 على سبيل المثال 93٪
من العملاء الذين تجاوزوا منتجات اللحوم
النباتية والموارد الداعمة للنمو
قاموا
أيضًا بشراء لحوم حيوانات حقيقية وبالنسبة
للمستهلكين الذين اشتروا
الوبر المستحيل من برجر كنج ، قال 70٪ منهم
إنهم يأكلون بانتظام  القليل من اللحوم ، هل
يعرفون أن فطائرهم الكبيرة كانت
تضع خططًا بالفعل ، فقد يبدو أن
أذواق المستهلكين تتغير ولكن ليس
ذلك تمامًا لأن اللحوم المزيفة اليوم
يتم إنشاء المنتجات لتبدو
تمامًا مثل اللحوم الحقيقية ، لكنني
أردت أن أرى ما إذا كان بإمكاننا استخدام العلم
لتفادي الجدل الأخلاقي بشكل أساسي
لتجاوز جميع القضايا
البيئية والسماح للمستهلكين بالاستمرار في فعل
ما يحبونه وهو تناول اللحوم
والإشارات المرئية  هي نفسها تمامًا ، فهي
تستجيب بنفس الطريقة ، ويمكنك استخدامها
لأكثر من مجرد برجر ، تجدر
الإشارة إلى أن
المنتجات النباتية والنباتية التقليدية لا تزال
خيارًا صحيًا بشكل عام ، وقد يتم إيقاف المستهلكين الذين
يبحثون عن خيار طعام طبيعي بالكامل
عن طريق  هذه المنتجات
قائمة طويلة من المكونات التي تثير القلق والتي
بالتأكيد ليست جديدة ولكن يجب أن يكون
هناك نوع من القانون لمنع الناس من
بيع الأطعمة السيئة وخاصة اللحوم الآن
يعتقد الخبراء أن شعبية
الركبة المزيفة
من المرجح أن تبقى هنا ويتوقع المحللون
أن بدائل  ستنمو اللحوم الحقيقية بدرجة
كبيرة بحيث أنه بحلول عام 2040 ، من
المحتمل ألا تأتي 60٪ من لحوم العالم من
الحيوانات المذبوحة لفهم
ذلك.  وإلقاء نظرة على المشاكل التي
يمكن أن تساعد اللحوم النباتية على حل
كمية الطعام التي نزرعها حاليًا
لن تطعم سوى نصف الأشخاص المتوقعين في
العالم البالغ عددهم تسعة وثمانية
مليارات شخص في عام 2050 بحلول ذلك الوقت ، من
المتوقع أن يزداد الطلب على المنتجات الحيوانية
بنسبة 70٪ ، هذا يعني أنه إذا
كان للعالم أن يحصل على ما يكفي من الغذاء ،
فسنحتاج إلى المزيد من الأراضي للمحاصيل والماشية ،
ولكن نظرًا لأن تغير المناخ يؤدي إلى مزيد من
الأراضي القاحلة وتصبح مصادر المياه
نادرة بشكل متزايد ، فقد لا يكون ذلك
ممكنًا وهذا هو السبب في أن الأمم المتحدة  يقول إن
المزارعين سيضطرون إلى بذل المزيد من الجهد مع
القليل الآن ، ألق نظرة على ما وراء
فطيرة برجر اللحوم النباتية مقارنة
بربع رطل من اللحم البقري الحقيقي بخلاف اللحوم ،
وله تأثير أقل بنسبة 99 في المائة على
ندرة المياه وتأثير أقل بنسبة 93 في المائة
على استخدام الأراضي 46  نسبة أقل من
الطاقة وتنبعث منها غازات دفيئة أقل بنسبة 90٪
وتزعم الشركة أن هذه
الفوائد تأتي دون التضحية بالكثير من
قوام الطعم أو حتى مظهر
طعامك الذي يفترض أن مزارعك فيه
100  فدان
يمكنك الآن زراعته على مساحة سبعة
أفدنة اعتدت أن تنمو على 100 فدان ، لذا أصبح لديك
93 فدانًا الآن لزراعة
محاصيل أخرى ، يمكنك تكوين ثروة من خلال
القيام بذلك الشيء الوحيد الذي
يكلف الآن في الولايات المتحدة.  ربع رطل من
اللحوم النباتية هو ما يقرب من 2 دولار أكثر من
اللحوم الحقيقية إذا تمكنا من الحصول على المذاق الصحيح ،
فلن يتوسع قرن بشكل صحيح إذا تمكنا من الحصول على
التغذية الصحيحة حيث تحصل على كل
الأشياء الرائعة الموجودة في اللحوم ولكن لا يوجد
سعر مناسب بالخارج  ثم
يصبح لماذا لا تفعل هذا